je suis contente je vais très bien ce
sera très beau lit ça les gars des
ministres n'a pas vu un monsieur bizarre
avec un grand carton pour moi un
monsieur bizarre avec un grand coeur
tout petit bras non non non mais tu sais
c'est un ça ne veut rien dire parce que
je t'aime mon travail qu'elle n'est pas
le temps de regarder ce qui se passe
dans le jardin alors demande plutôt à
françois il sera peut-être bon je vais
être bientôt dans serait trop bien
dedans
dis-moi casimir un couac est ce que ces
ronds françois tu m'as fait peur je
croyais que tu verras si en train de
lire ce que j'ai mis avec le bruit que
tu fais
j'aurais eu du mal dit dont le moral a
l'air plutôt bon loin
et alors eh bien j'aimerais savoir dans
quoi tu seras bien comment est-ce que tu
peux un courant qui mirent tout chanter
à tue-tête pom pom pom là dedans je
serai bien c'est un secret à se créer
chip qui moquaient séméria voir avec qui
as-tu rendez-vous permet comment sais-tu
celui là je n'en ai parlé à personne
eh bien disons grâce à mon intuition je
peux la voir
qui ça mais ton intuition je voudrais
savoir ce que c'est que cette machine
qui permet de deviner tout mon voeu que
gémir l'intuition n'est pas une machine
non si tu veux scène c'est un don nous
avons tous de comprendre quelque chose
sans qu'on nous l'expliqué ainsi toi je
t'ai entendu demandé à julie s'il avait
vu un grand monsieur bizarre avec un
carton sous le bras alors j'ai eu
l'intuition que tu avais un rendez-vous
mais personne ne doit être au courant
casimir je te promets de n'en parler à
personne parce que c'est un secret et
personne ne doit savoir que j'ai un
rendez vous
oui je suis architecte et j'ai rendu
avec monsieur casimir calme toi ça va
s'arranger je lui parlais à mes la
moitié de la surprise et gâchis bonjour
monsieur monsieur quasi sûrs je pense
non non non moi je m'appelle françois
mon ami casimir qui est là bas sera là
dans un petit instant il est tentant de
se remettre de l'émotion que lui a causé
votre arrivée ah mais c'est étonnant
j'avais rendez vous avec monsieur quasi
il voulait que personne ne soit au
courant
[Musique]
je suis désolé il voulait sans doute
faire ses amis la surprise de la
nouvelle maison que je dois me contre 12
5 10 ou salaires la coudée monsieur
l'architecte je crois que vous avez
parlé trop fort ah c'est mon défaut je
sers j'espère que monsieur casimir ne
sera pas trop fâché car c'est cet après
midi que nous le pourrons discuter des
plans
il est bête tout est issu alors là moi
je crains que nous n'en ayons pour un
bon moment avant que casimir ne soient
calmés à rouler vous c'est ma faute je
suis désolé eh bien écoutez je vais en
profiter pour aller voir le terrain où
doit être construite la nouvelle mais
sans fête attendue
je veux en profiter pour vous laisser
quelques croix qui est monsieur kazim
pourra consulter et je m'en fous casimir
les émirs ne boude pas mon vieux tu sais
c'était quand même une bonne surprise
tiens regarde voilà quelques croquis que
l'architecte m'a laissé tu vas pouvoir
choisir ta maison regarde quasiment ça
te plaît qu'est ce que tu en penses
bright sont trois mâles mais comment
est-ce que j'aurai les reconnaître
savoir celle quand j'ai choisi puisqu'il
n'ya pas en donnant dessus ah oui c'est
vrai ça plaisait mais on va demander aux
enfants
d'accord les enfants qu'il fasse assez
venez venez des enfants casimir a besoin
de votre aide
voilà casimir venez venez les enfants
vous venez m'aider à choisir maryse
douala qu'est ce que c'est que cette
maison didier talent et à rendre cet
exemple c'est un mélange de deux styles
le style arabe et le style espagnol
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est et ça
s'appelle un tipi une tante d'indiens en
haut de la tour
il ya un espace libre pour que la fumée
qui s'en aller ça qu'est ce que c'est
où trouve-t-on les chalets dans la
montagne
gilani
les maris dans un chalet et ça s'est
construit en quoi un chalet en bois
ce sont des planches bon qu'est-ce qui
après c'est une maison de merde et des
équipements c'est une maison qui est
montée sur pilotis psa sont des pilotis
et où trouve-t-on ces maisons dans des
villages construits sur l'eau pour pas
dans les pieds mouillés dynamo après
bien sûr l'oise et combien de toile à de
toi elle une forme très spécial relève
comme ça c'est magnifique non oh qu'est
ce que c'est que ça ça c'est une isba
mbia moutons ces maisons bon ou marie l
il marque c'est une isba oui c'est en
russie fj est en bois ça ce sont des
rondins c'est très très beau vous avez
la décoration autour des fenêtres et les
folles nuits les plats table larmes
stéphane de voir ça c'est pas exactement
natale ce sont des roseaux des cian il
savait dans quelle région de france on
trouve ces maisons très bien olivier en
camargue et pas toi tu es un jour très
beau la camargue
qu'est ce que c'est que ça priscilla sur
le toit
il dépanne mais ça s'appelle du chaume
et le chaume s'est effectivement comme
disent les sommes oui marie c'est une
chaumière
tu sais ce que ça ne chôme pas l'une
chômage stéphane le disait stéphane
c'est de la paille dont on a retiré le
grain des failles très longue
une autre fois on couvrait les les
maisons les maisons assez pauvre de
pareilles de chaume
qu'est ce que c'est que ça pour les
joints queen
ça ce sont des tubes ce sont des tuiles
romanes c'est ce que 7 des tuiles ce
sont des carreaux de terre cuite qui ont
des formes différentes et la moyenne
elles sont comme ça elle rentre les unes
dans les autres
c'est un mas fasse trop dans quelle
région donc il reste de la france
canarie c'est oui
dans le midi la france à marseille au
mal qu'est ce que c'est c'est une maison
non quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya au la gamme
des cigognes en france non mais dans
l'air depuis quelques fois elle se pose
en alsace au port de l'air las et
regardait en alsace très bien y regarder
c'est ce que c'est c'est eh oui c'est ça
comme ici c'est sur ces barres de bois
ce sont des colombages et ici les
ardoises sont rendus aux bouffes voyez
est ce que c'est et ardoises oui venez y
en a une pour écrire c'est une pierre
bleuâtre qui se divise allamand
plusieurs feuillets avec décret
récemment foncièrement classe et on les
met aussi sur les toits des maisons
l'oiseau est compris dans le prix de la
maison ça je ne suis pas désignée faudra
demander à notre ami de la chine je
constate avec bonheur que vous avez
consulté mes plans et monsieur
l'architecte
je sais exactement comment il faut
construire ma maison et je vais vous le
dire à mes envies
ce cas ci c'est une affaire de spécial
et je ne me compare pas nous nous met en
colère dit monsieur d'architecte
peut-être pourriez-vous lui faire le
dessin de sa maison telle qu'il la veut
bibi mis d'accord d'accord je ne demande
qu'une seule chose se faire plaisir mais
se qualifie on comprenait les iem alors
venez par là parce que c'est un secret
j'aurais voulu coller au mur
[Musique]
moi c'est leur est en retard il a promis
de me poser torse tort je suis vraiment
impatient l'arrivée le voilà
mademoiselle monsieur je vous apporte le
dessin de la maison de monsieur casimir
j'ai respecté à la lettre ces
habitations mais c'est un tas de ruines
kazim et
[Musique]